our owner in new york city getting
hauled away in handcuffs after defying
covet rules and declaring his business
an autonomous zone danny presti speaking
out
we followed everything that their
science
everything the governor the the mayor's
orders since
march and just kept going kept going
we were literally stripped down to
nothing and not just us
this is all small businesses everybody
who works in those small businesses
we were crippled down to almost nothing
and
meanwhile more democrats accused of
hypocrisy over violating covet
guidelines
san francisco mayor london breed
reportedly attended a dinner party
at that upscale restaurant french
laundry the day after california
governor
gavin newsom was there for a party days
later she banned
all indoor dining in san francisco and
the mayor of
austin texas just got busted for making
this video
telling people to stay at home while he
was vacationing
in mexico juan why do these stories
continue
politicians flouting their own
guidelines yeah these guys are
hypocrites and they should be called out
for it so
i don't think there's any question about
it you know these are to my mind this is
bad actions by politicians because
people follow examples and so that's
not good but i'd rather have bad acting
politicians than bad policies that hurt
people and the policies are the right
policies their policies
are good and why don't they follow them
and no i think that i think that they
should but
you know i think elites sometimes they
they have their own rules but
you know what we should be doing is what
we should be doing the real person
that's hurting people if you're one of
those
politicians whose actions are actually
having an adverse effect
is mitch mcconnell right now blocking
blocking any kind of congressional help
for people who are what does austin
mayor digest
because this is really something that
facebook video message
it was posted november 9th it was two
days after his daughter's wedding
he said on there we need to stay home if
you can we need to keep the numbers down
now is not the time to relax
he has since confirmed that he made that
video
and delivered that message to austinites
while he was on vacation in mexico with
eight people
now is not the time to relax with a rum
runner in your hands
oh spf 15 slathered all over your fat
chest
and this guy's disgusting he should stay
in mexico we shouldn't let him back in
um would i like i don't like what i'm
seeing out in staten island like you can
loot a business but you can't open a
business here in new york city thanks de
blasio
remember this was only supposed to be
temporary these lockdowns even the who
says lockdowns are a bad idea it was
supposed to buy time to have
hospital capacity i just looked at the
hospital capacity here in manhattan
we're fine whole city is fine there's
plenty of beds so what are they doing
they're basically shutting down small
businesses and then the politicians
aren't sending them the stimulus checks
it's how you destroy a country and now
you saw the autonomous zone out in
seattle
and they had other autonomous zone out
here okay two liberal cities
one was pro-business it was anti-police
but they get treated
completely different one let's fester
for i think
23 days and then one gets shut down
after
what 24 hours and the one they had two
what murders they had assaults they had
businesses being shook and down
they had vandalism and this one a couple
people got drunk
i mean there people got shot here people
just took a few shots
but all of a sudden the guy's arrested
for that it's sick man craig you really
feel for these restaurant owners i mean
how can they continue to survive with
these restrictions
the thing is we said this at the
beginning of this whole nine months ago
when it started
that our our job is to give opinions but
we almost we almost have no skin in this
game
because we're not giving up any we're
we're on tv
so like we aren't gonna give up our
salaries and we're not gonna lose our
medical insurance and we're not gonna
move back at home
that's what's happening to these people
who own bars this is what's happening to
the waitresses and the bartenders and
the people in the
small businesses they aren't gonna be
bailed out like the looters were after
the riots you know yeah politicians
bailing out looters but they're not
bailing out these guys so it's easy for
people to say that these people got to
follow the rules when we're on tv
so i think that like it's we got to stop
listening to the politicians
we got to start listening to the people
we have to listen to them and what they
believe is right because
generally right now they've been told a
lot of stuff that isn't true
and and their and their livelihoods and
careers are being destroyed taken
yeah why is it okay for people can go in
a bar
literally a few streets down from this
bar owner
in staten island that i i expect
politicians to be hypocritical
but i really am stunned by their level
of idiocy
because there is now a hopelessness
among these bar and restaurant owners
and a desperation where
you see something like this with this
bar in staten island
this man has nothing to lose and
everything to lose at the same time i
say
over and over again if there's one thing
i've repeated all year is
i am grateful to have a job i am really
lucky to have a job and i can't
i don't really know what they're going
through but i feel for them
and to correct you on something juan
mitch mcconnell
and the senate republicans tried to move
forward
on a half a trillion dollar stimulus
package
twice and twice the democrats in the
senate
voted to not even start debate on it
there is a hundred and thirty five
hundred and forty billion dollars in
leftover money from the paycheck
protection program
that just needs to simply be reallocated
by nancy pelosi let me just where is
that money
it is nowhere half a trillion dollars
in money that is unspent from the spring
package
it needs to be realizated
shouting but you don't you can't refute
that idea that democrats have acted have
had a bill on the table have passed
the house oh bipartisan republicans to
bail out
wait wait republicans and democrats put
forward yesterday a bipartisan proposal
less than what the president and
mcconnell
are millions of americans democrats
failed the american people
over and over again i can agree on that
one